I worked on myself and I gave to others
and now I'm learning to give to myself
as well I don't know does anyone else
struggle with that yes I would say as a
mom it's very hard to take care of
[Music]
yourself is there something you do to
take care of yourself and to fill your
own cup just recently started therapy
because
[Music]
life really like I don't know why I'm
here but I feel like I need to prepare
myself for what can come I have great
care of she's awesome and she just said
your lists are all about taking care of
other people make sure on your list you
have things to take care of yourself
well it sounds like we're on such a
similar journey I mean I think we just
said the same
thing I'm with you I really am it's
starting to live a new life where you
are in the mix and for it not to be a
selfish concept